hello and welcome to this little
announcement video yeah this is a very
short notice video but ok maybe some of
you still I able to catch the show it's
a live show I'm going to be live on the
air in roughly 90 minutes from from now
this is one said short notice and we're
doing a runny on chest 24 I'm going to
play a band to blitz ashni on chest 24
yeah they have lots of shows on them
yeah I cruise you see some on the left
left picture yung gusto Saunders has
been tablets and I'm going to join them
yeah lineup of players doing been to
blitz for them and today will be kind of
a test run it's a thursday afternoon
german time it's a 44 in the in the
afternoon in in germany which makes it
what is that US East Coast time wow it's
like early right 10 a.m. yeah not the
most friendly time for those guys
getting in their offices but this is a
test run today I'm going to play and
chat a little bit like 90 minutes
roughly it will probably be and if this
works out all right we'll probably make
a regular show out of that that will be
in the evening hours in terms of
european time kind of comparable to what
we have one on Mondays yeah if you are
able to join on let's make sure make
sure to do that I will play a just 24
premium members by the way it's not what
I do on Mondays I will play everybody if
you are watching this year and you have
a premium account I'm just 24 you can
challenge me and I will play you so make
sure to join this will also be
accessible later on the YouTube channel
of chess 24 so if you don't manage life
you can also check this channel out
thanks guys